الجزء الأجنبي
[الموسيقى]
هو أنني لست لاعب غولف ولكننا رأينا هذا
المفهوم في أوروبا
مشينا هناك وكان لدينا هذا
التأثير المذهل لأنه عندما ترى الفن
لأول مرة تحت الضوء الأسود مع نظارات ثلاثية الأبعاد،
يصبح الفن حيًا
وبعد ذلك، لقد انبهرت حقًا، وكانت
هذه هي اللحظة التي اعتقدت فيها حسنًا،
فلنحاول جلب هذا المفهوم إلى دبي،
لدينا ثلاث غرف مختلفة ذات طابع خاص، واحدة
تحت الماء، وواحدة تسمى الصحراء
في الليل، وواحدة هي الفضاء، وفي كل
غرفة قمنا بدمجها
الثقافة العربية وعلى وجه التحديد أيضًا
تاريخ دبي، على سبيل المثال في
الغرفة تحت الماء لدينا غواص اللؤلؤ
وهو التقليد هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة وفي
الصحراء قمنا برسم
رجلهم المحلي مع طائر الصقر وخيمة عربية في
الليل  الصحراء وفي الفضاء، قمنا
برسم رائد فضاء عليه علم الإمارات العربية المتحدة
قبل أن تذهب
إيمان سوري إلى الفضاء، لذا فقد
رأينا ذلك بالفعل نوعًا ما قادمًا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]